the duma bled Valachi a national park in
southwestern romania is an oasis of
unspoiled nature high above it is a man
balancing on a slack line Flavio Genesco
is an acrobat and extreme athlete he
cycles sits and walks at dizzying
heights he's not so much trying for new
records as being an ambassador for his
native Romania and that explains why
he's chosen this national park my
philosophy is when it comes to balance
is just try to experiment with
everything that you can find can just go
longer and longer and higher and higher
but this is not the only thing that you
can do with it you can just take it to
other places China's who is trying out
his latest idea here an illuminated
slackline that he'll try to walk at
night he and his team have to carry in
all the equipment over 30 kilograms per
person the spot he's chosen for the
slackline is far from any road it's a
feat of strength before he even gets
started
doing a high line at night is hard
because most of the balance comes from
your vision so when you can't see much
when you can see the anchors it's harder
to keep your posture to stay vertical
tanesco has grabbed the public's
attention with his stunts the most
spectacular among them has racked up
nearly 3 million views on YouTube his
ascent of an old industrial smoke stock
romania's second highest structure he
balanced atop the 280 meter tall chimney
with no safety nets or lines flavia
chair nesco is romania's best known
extreme athlete he appears on TV and in
promotional films
in 2014 he rode through his home region
on a unicycle for a documentary titled
Transylvania dragon covering over 2,500
kilometers and showing off his acrobatic
skills at various spots along the way he
quit his job as a programmer to take
part in the film and to pursue his dream
even though it meant a cut in his
earnings in order to do something really
good in life you have to focus on it you
have to give your way yourself to that
particular thing so for exploring my
sport and for leaving an adventure life
you have to be free you have to have
more time for that in the National Park
his team sets up and makes the final
preparations for the lighted line the
slacklines webbing is wrapped with
reflective tape so Flavio turn s who can
see it in the dark the first tests are
run in daylight
then he tries his first steps at night I
was nervous in the beginning that this
line can be hard especially having to do
it at night some of the LED lights were
pointed right in my eyes and I was
blinded and I couldn't really see what
was important for me but then I I got
into it and I understand the line so it
was good 25 meters above the ground step
by step flavia chair nesco gains
confidence after all it's just a
question of nerves of steel and perfect
balance
you